[Music]
so hello everybody welcome to my latest
less losses class sorry my name is Pippa
cuenca I'm gonna Spanish Grandmaster
happy to be here with all of you like to
invite you to participate in the class
as usual so you have any comments
questions please go ahead and today I
would like to show you a game I played
against Ganguly Ganguly is one of the
best Indian chess players he is above
2600 yeah he's a pretty strong player
this gang was played in the 2012 Spanish
lake it's a pretty strong League where a
lot of top players come and yeah so I
hoped you liked the game so maybe we can
start analyzing it so Ganguly play d4
and I decide to go for native six c4 was
played and c5 now White has several
options y could take this pawn and after
this move normally black just goes he's
six I think is going to be able to
recapture the opponent c5 and then
there's no trouble
so normally white here chooses between
93 and d5 and in this case Ganguly went
for the main line d5 and now I decided
to play one of my favorite openings is
the banker gambit the move b5 the idea
is that after taking on b5 do you want
to sacrifice another poem by playing a6
and what's blacks idea here well
basically after BTX is six you have
sacrifice upon but in return you're
gonna play like g6 Bishop d7 you're
gonna have a really strong Bishop and
then to open files that in your future
you want to use for example with your
looks so one of the plan is to go g6
Bishop g7 short Castle d6 Bishop takes
Knight Millie 7 and rook f8 look F to b8
sorry and there will be a lot of
pressure of course
y can play of the moves here for example
basics is pretty interesting
mmm not upsetting the pawn sacrifice
also Knight c3 it's a pretty interesting
move hxb 5 and E 4 this is a crazy
variation for example B 495 and now it's
actually really really risky to take
this pawn on e4 the best move is just t6
but if you take this pawn on e4 after
Queen e2 there are a lot of troubles for
black for example black plays Knight f6
what will you play here with with with
the white pieces you see the move
exactly 96 checkmate
so some people have fell for this trap
but we're not gonna do it so why to
kanae's sorry after a 6 Ganguly took on
a 6 and here I decided just to go g6 so
there's no rush actually to taking this
point you're gonna take it sooner or
later and Ganguly played Knight c3 at
this point I took an a6 this is the main
line today the main line is considered
to be Bishop g7 the so-called balloon of
each variations so Grandmaster Parana
which introduced this idea cuz after the
move Bishop takes a 6e for Bishop takes
f1 Kintex f1 dense line is considered to
be a little bit better for white it's
pretty known for black and white plan is
rather simple you want to go Knight f3
g3 and you wanna castle artificially in
d2 and then bring the rook to the center
etc etc so this is considered to be one
of the most critical lines of the Benko
but instead this per unit balloon of
each variations or it goes Bishop g7 and
then what you want to do is of the e4
shirt Castle Knight e3 you wanna play
Queen a5 and then you want to take on a6
the idea is that you want to recapture
later with the Queen and then make
castle in difficult right but okay 2012
main line was Bishop a6 so I went Bishop
basics and here there are different
setups right here that you can use
for example as I told you if four is the
critical line but then also you can try
to go for the fee and Cato asked and
coolly did so not a 3 d6 + g3 whites it
is very simple do you want to put the
bishop on g2 the insure castle and then
you wanna continue development all right
so I play Bishop g7 and Bishop d2 it's
well known that the best setup for y
here in these types of positions is to
try to get the double fianchetto got
double fee on keto sorry
so for example you go something like
char castle here then or let's say
Knight B to d7 short castle short castle
and route b1 white wants go b3 and
Bishop b2 and he if white manages that
it will get a really nice position let's
say something like Queen c7 b3 and yeah
white is considered to be a bit better
so black has to do something to stop
that and that's why night f2 d7 is
pretty interesting so now it's pretty
tough for white to go for this b3 idea
since this we're targeting the c3 Knight
right and black spike is going to be
sure Castle Knight b6 Knight B to d7 and
then many times you want to jump to this
c4 squared with this night then the
Queen can join the party via a 5 and
then the other look finally to be 8 so
this is blacks plant and white here her
has different options the main line is
just your castle right this is the most
natural move here but this is a really
interesting light that maybe you can try
in one of your tournament games so Queen
c2 it's a pretty aggressive line let's
say Knight b6 and h4 so do delay your
castling and then you want to attack
ready for example here 86 it's a really
interesting move and 85 is considered to
be a mistake I'm going to try to show
you why so h5 95 is the point now this
square is very weak you can never play
f6 since there's weight square on e6
right so after shortcuts all you're
going
try to vote g4 and try to create a very
very tough attack against Blacks game
alright so Quincy - it's a very
interesting move but main line goes
after short castle
so Ganguly played short castle and I
played night to be six white here played
Queen c2 it's a really natural move so
in many cases you protect the c3 Knight
so you are aiming to go for this be
three setups and then you give a space
for this rook once you come to d1 and
protect the d5 phone
now Knight a to d7 was played in this
game and I want to ask you what do you
think about this rook b1 move because
many like many lines you want to go b3
right so you're gonna go be three
straight away because for example this
ninety five here and then you can never
take because the rookin egg one is
hanging right so you could try to go
first group b1
but it's actually a bad move you know
the reason guys from YouTube you can
also answer this question it has a huge
drawback this route b1 do you find the
move
Bishop d3 no right Mitchell takes it to
know so what's a move exactly Bishop c4
now there is a double attack on the a2
point and on the d5 point I have seen so
many people falling for this trick like
to just you're just going to win a pawn
back so let's say for example 92 we
should take say - and how about after
drew k1 what do you play here with the
black pieces this wood takes the fight
perfect so you can't take on d5 because
the rookin a1 is hanging and if you take
on a 8 you can just take back with the
bishop and blacks opponent with a really
healthy position so that's why rook big
one is not a very good move and instead
my opponent played Knight d2 pretty
decent move covering the c-4 square and
I went for sure castle so here at this
point blacks threatening to take on c3
right we couldn't do that before
because after Bishop takes c3 Queen
takes c3 and now that rook on h8 is just
hanging right so we can't take on e2
because
Queen takes h8 and black wax winning
sorry but after sure castle we are
threatened actually to take on c3
because at the Queen takes c3 there is
no Rogan h8 right so white has to do
something about this e to pawn and
that's why ganguly played rook e1
protecting this point he's ready maybe
to push this pawn to e4 and here there
were many decent moves so for example 95
in order to jump to c4 I decided to go
for Bishop b7 because I think his idea
was just to play b3 at this point
because not the bishop c3 Queen the
Queen c3 the pawn on d5 is protected by
this bishop so I played maybe not maybe
not the most natural move for the human
eye I played Bishop d7 but the idea is
to force efore after player sorry after
white plays d4 and then the d3 square
could be very weak so now I could go
back to a 6 and then
try to jump with my Knight to e5 and
then we're looking for some nice squares
on d3 and now actually b3 is not
possible why b3 is not possible
just try to remember we have brought
another guy to put pressure on d5 so
what do we play
we should take c3 or yeah that's a
possibility but also 90 xe5 right
because this broken a1 is unprotected so
if you take now with the knight on d5
then we should take say one if white
bishop takes on d5
then just bishop takes d5 and again we
have a really good position if white
doesn't take on d5 then we got the
bishop pair we got a nice center and
black is much better in this position
right so Knight takes d5 is the solution
so that's why b3 is not possible and
ganguly played the most natural movie
for now once I have force this point to
come to e4 and this T 3 square is pretty
weak so I just go back to Bishop is
doing nothing on on b7 and now well
aiming to put some piss on the d3
squared that's why Ganguly played
prophylactically and played the move
rook to d1 so he wants to remove the
knight from d2 if I go 95 and then
covered the d3 squared right so 9 if I
was played threatening Bishop d3 or 93
and he had to cover this d3 squared
that's why he went Knight to f1 at this
point and here the move Knight B to C 4
it's very typical in these positions
because if you go b3 now in this
position what do you play here with the
black pieces
it's not an easy move though any ideas
the guys from the YouTube channel
nope yes 93 93 I think I can just take
this night and what's your idea
okay so 93 is not possible and the movie
is Queen to a5 and the thing is if white
takes on c4 you just take with your
night there's no way of protecting this
c3 Knight you play Bishop b2 then just
Knight XB 2 followed by Bishop c3 right
and then if you remove this Knight let's
say 2 e 2 then the rook on a1 is hanging
so that's why b3 is done it's not an
option it's actually a bad move and you
can't also really play f4 here you will
love to kick this Knight back right but
then after Knight g4 there are so many
threats what's the threat for example
let's say if I play a three stupid move
what do you play here Knight G to e3 I
think white can take and if you take
back then Bishop takes
so we blunder a piece but now there's a
problem after this f4 move White has
weakened this diagonal so Bishop default
check perfect now white campus can put
sorry any piece in between and he's
forced to go to 8:1 enough tonight f2 he
can resign kim jiwon and night texted
one with a check so that's why f4 is a
really risky move and you don't want to
play that too so in this game ganguly
played a 4 a 4 maybe he wants to jump to
b5 and I played Queen a 5 this is the
typical plant for black so now all black
pieces are perfectly placed then we're
the only missing piece who is not taking
action jet is this rookie from f8 so
just wanna play rook F to be 8 and then
put a lot of pressure on these 2 files
right Ganguly played Group B 1
he wants to kick
this night right so the rukon big one is
better placed than on a one since there
are no troubles with the bishop so black
played Luke F to be eight and now what
happens if white goes b3 it's a bad move
but why so Orlando the YouTube channel
Baptists desert lightning you guys have
any idea
it's clear that if we go back with our
night let's say 96 then black completes
development let's say Bishop b2 and then
we don't have nice squares for our necks
right and now we're a little bit stuck
here on the a5 on the on the B file so
we cannot retreat at night so what do we
play
all right so blacks idea or Queen before
it's maybe interesting but I think I can
just take tonight so X meters is saying
Queen before sorry batches but then I
can just take tonight right and the
route can be one is protected by the
knight and the Queen so actually Queen
before doesn't work black let's move
here it's not a free check so be sure
takes f3 Queen takes c3 Queen takes c3
Bishop takes c3 and white can't capture
the knight on c4 since we're gonna take
this rook on b1 and now there will be a
lot of pressure in this position for
white since now we're just aiming to go
9 85 and there is no efficient way of
protecting the b3 pawn this is very
important in the bank on gambit and it
happens many times if one of the points
on the Queen side fall then probably the
second one will fall too and then we'll
have this passport on the C file alright
so b3 was not possible that's why
ganguly played 982 he's insisting in
playing b3 and he if he manages to play
be free he will have a really nice
position so we have to be really careful
here with the black pieces and now
there's only one move one good move for
black here in this position
the move is pretty beautiful so it's
Bishop c8 retreating your Bishop and
then you are creating two threats
the first one is quite simple to just
want to check this pawn on e4 right the
second one is to bring this B this
bishop story to g4 and then you suddenly
see that there are no squares available
for this rook because the route can't go
to e 1 since the Queen is here the route
can't come to d2 because there is a
knight no d3 because this night so
Bishop g4 is really nasty threat and f3
just not possible because we we can't
just take that pawn right so that's why
Ganguly had to come back to c3 and
married to was not a good move because
of Bishop c8 now he has to come back to
c3 and he has lost a temple right
so I played Bishop g4 in this position
now he can go to e1 since now the night
is in between the Queen and the rook and
here there were different alternatives I
decided to go for night to a3 which
we're gonna analyze very soon Queen
before was very interesting like pouring
a lot of pressure in this position but
93 it seems interesting too because now
white is forced to take B takes c3 rook
takes me one and can't you take with the
knight now would you take with the
knight or with the Queen
so you have five seconds in your clock
you have to choose this happens all the
time to us Queen right because if you
take with the night then there is
Queenie one so you rather lose peace
than a rook right but we have to
remember that black has sacrificed
already a piece of because we played 93
so Queen B 1 Queen takes c3 and in terms
of heavy pieces material is balanced but
now we can see that these two points are
very very weak and we got this c5
Passport it's a really important point
in all Benko and games so at this point
Ganguly played rook III this route was
attacked so this move is perfectly
natural so just kicking this Quinn from
c3 and now Queen a5 was played and route
b3 here the point is if we take the pawn
on e4 then rook b8 takes takes Bishop f8
and Bishop h6 or Bishop g5 and suddenly
black could be in trouble so that's why
here I wanted to give some pressure to
my kin and that's why I played h5 maybe
86 was better so we covered the g5
square there is no Bishop g5 as it
happened in the game so I went age 5 and
Ganguly played Bishop g5 putting some
pressure on the e7 pomp here I decided
to play f6 sorry Bishop f6 I'm Ganguly
plate group B a check and at this point
I made the first mistake
so in this game you're gonna see a lot
of mistakes and this is the first one so
clearly was just much better to take
straight away on be a queen to expiate
and King g7 because in the game I played
King g7 straight away and then he took
on f6 and took on a a and clearly the
Queen is much better placed on a5 than
on 88 we got more active squares and
then we can attack
also white-skinned right so rook takes
ba was much better move but I decided
just to play King g7 so he took I took
rook takes a8 Queen takes a a and now F
for attacking this night what would you
jump now we got only two available
squares c4 or d7
d7 g7 okay yeah so now a tree could be
played but still you got this e to write
e to a square so I think both worked so
I decided to go tonight C for more
active square putting pressure on the a
three-point and he went Queen to b5 in
this position the bad news for is we
can't take on a three if we take on e3
what's the move here for white how white
wins
chop the night Queen b3 exactly great
now we're gonna take this night on a
three in the next move so that's why I
had to play Knight a5 and something
hasn't gone well here because now I'm
not putting pressure on the a pawns then
he's got a active Queen and here okay
the best move here was a tree just
kicking this Bishop Bishop c8 and let's
say keen x2 he decided to go Knight to
e3 and then I played Queen a7 now I
could have some c4 moves and then this
idea could be very dangerous for white
so he decided to go h3 and now the point
is when this screen with this screen on
a 7 I can retreat this Bishop to d7
instead of ca because now the Queen is
protecting this square so now we're
going to win a temple Queen B 2 and C 4
was played I was trying to activate my
queen through this diagonal so Queen C 3
was played and then finally I managed to
take one of your of these pawns but then
the bad news for aya is that White has a
nice Center this point could be
dangerous for white but also could be a
weakness for black because it's easily
attacked right for example with the
bishop on f1 etc etc why I decided to go
here g4 h takes H takes and now he's
introducing these threats for example g5
and then I could have a lot of troubles
here alright so how do you stop g5 in
this position what do we do against this
threat
we got 10 seconds in the clock you gotta
play a move it's not easy right resign
somebody say King g8 okay
King J it is a very interesting move
since now white can take Queen f6 toss
tonight only three is hanging soaked in
da it was a possibility I decided to go
for Knight to b3 the point is I wanna
maybe exchange a heavy piece here so
after g5 I could play Queen to d4 let's
say for example g5 queen d4 takes takes
Knight takes the point is I got this 92
fork and then I will take this pawn on
f4
I'm position is more or less balanced
right so at this point
Ganguly of course he was trying to to
beat me yes he's a better player so he
wanted to keep some pieces in the board
yeah so he played King f2 protecting
this III night now maybe he is
threatening to take on c4 with the Queen
sits now denied only three is protected
so I played Bishop b5 protecting the c4
pawn bishop f1 was played he's putting a
lot of pressure on the c4 form but now
if four is not protected so I went night
c5 here in this position just attacking
the e4 pawn and of course if he takes on
c4 what happens Knight takes e4 and then
the Queen is just for us
so he went King f3 and I kept putting
pressure on the e4 pawn so I went Queen
c7 attacking this efore pawn again he
takes on c4 something Bad's gonna happen
after Queen takes e4 so he had to
protect the e4 point in the only way he
can so he played Queen to d4 and now I
saw a way of trying to find a triple
repetition here so I played Knight b3
attacking the Queen Queen B 295 and I
thought I was going to draw this
like he would be happy with the draw
here but no he played here Queen c2 the
thing is he takes the bishop on b5 then
there's Queenie for King F - Quinta
except for King 82 and 94 and there are
so many threats Knight c3 Queen f2 93
blacks better blacks winning here so he
had to protect this pawn on C - sorry
this pawn on e4 and he played Queen c2
instead of Queen d4 to avoid triple
repetition alright so I still play
Knight b3 nowadays this fork here and
Queen B - 95 Queen B one he chooses
another square so I went Knight B 3 now
in several instead of d4
I am threatening to go to d2 right
he played King f2 so I decided to go
Bishop a6 here because we want to play
an ID - right but the bishop on b5 is
just hanging
so I played Bishop h6 here and we are
threatening to go 92 followed by Knight
takes e4
so he went Bishop g2 probably he was
risking too much he probably should go
here Queen c2 and then after 95 kinna 3
then upset the triple repetition but
then he went Bishop g2 here and now
Knight c5 were jumping to d3 f4 is a
really wait square and he went King to
g3 now there's no way of putting more
pressure on the e4 pawn so I found
another active diagonal Queen egg 7 this
night on e3 is not protected if he goes
back to f2 we got this in d3 square to
jump with our night so he went g5 and I
played Knight d7 protecting f6 tucky
this night on 83
94 was played increasing the pressure on
this epic exit sponsoring and I went
Queen d4 and at this point black is much
better that's why this loss was so
painful for me I was almost crying in my
hotel room after a lost his game because
black was so much better here that the
queen is centralized
I got a passed pawn here on the C file
and yeah but he started to set some
traps
he played queen h1 here aiming to go
Queen eight-six at some point and then
song f5 moves for example if I play c3
here Queen eight-six king g8 and f5 and
suddenly the position is extremely
complicated because if you take on f5
then G takes f6 and now he's threatening
mate white could be winning so after
Queen h1 I decided to take on g 5g f
young he went f5 here again it's got the
same idea if I take on a5 he could go
Queen e86
followed by Queen g5 check so probably
here Knight f6 was good enough but then
I decided to go keen f8 maybe the most
natural human move because after Queen
eight-six
then I can just retreat my queen to g7
right so queen eight six Queen g7 Queen
g5 f 6 so he wants to give a check on
the 8th right that's checkmate so if I
go 3 3 then Queen da checkmate that's it
so f6 queena for Knight e5
and then after 98 c 5d takes e5 black is
much better
he went Queen III and now G takes f 5
check kin f2 and what would you play
here with with the black pieces you have
any suggestion guys from YouTube what do
you play here with black black it's
almost winning don't mess it up like me
BAM what do you play here
f-for right disalignment batches cloned
rock and roll they are all saying F for
it's the most natural move and it's
really good
so F for the point is now this Queen can
also come to g3 for example if white
goes Queen b6 in order to trap this
Bishop after Queen g3 white can almost
resign after okay you can never go to g1
right so let's say after king of one
Queen d3 if you go to g1 you can
exchange Queens let's say on d4 or on e3
and blacks winning and then if you go to
e1 whites and play Queen c3 check King
of one Queen c1 King up to 22 and after
kim ji-won again Queen d4 or Queen III
checked and this game is completely
waiting for black look at this -
Passport it's actually quite easy for
black to win the same game but instead
of g3 I went Queen c7 I was somehow
scary about this Queen b6 move I thought
I was going to lose this bishop I had
like two minutes in my clock and then I
even see f4 or at least I thought that
after Queen g3 there was not something
there was nothing after king of one but
here Queen a6 was played Queen g7 only
move now because you can't go Queen f7
to protect sorry Queen f7 to protect the
f6 pawn right why we can't go kin f7
this is an easy one
Queen 87 right and then blacks losing
the Queen so that's why I had to go
Queen g7 and then he exchanged now in
much better conditions right because now
he's taking the pawn on f5 material is
balanced right still black is better why
black is better because we have a
protected passport which is always very
interesting and this pawn on f5 is in a
light Square and we can attack this
point at some point then we got the C
passport and
I went kina fate here my planning just
very simple I want to go kindy six and
then tried to put a little pressure on
the defy phone so he stopped up by
playing day six and now I went King he
ate in this position I just want to go
Kean d7 and captured this pawn still
it's not that easy because he plays
Bishop c6 check King d8 and King III he
also has to stop this c3 pawn so I went
c3 it's not easy for y2 to put pressure
on this he pawn right because the d3
square is covered so here I thought like
okay I can never lose this hand game
right so he played a for Bishop c8
putting pressure here it's actually not
even possible to take this pawn after a
five because he's threatening to play a
six so I can never take on f5 so I went
back to a six
Bishop way for both of us we started to
play around
I played King see a bishop p8 I went
Bishop c4 it's actually really difficult
to make any progress for both type both
sides right Bishop c6 Bishop f6 Bishop
a4
Bishop c4 King efore and here I where I
play Bishop b5 there's always this idea
so deflection yeah white can't take on
b5 because of c2 and then black wins
so Bishop c2 was played check on c6
clean d3 and now this point is gonna
fall but this point is gonna fall - so
keen d7 Kintex III King takes d6
King takes c4 check Bishop b5 e 4 and I
and I and I thought - okay I can never
lose this right so even if he manages to
promote this point I will sacrifice it I
will sacrifice my Bishop and then I
somehow I'll collect this poem from f5 I
can never lose this at this game right
so a 6
I played III and he went Bishop d3
and at this point I went completely
crazy that's why this game was so
painful yeah after six hours game eighty
moves I was playing a really nice game a
lot of mistakes here the most natural
move is keen to e5 and then after a
seven let's say kindy for Bishop f1 King
e5 Bishop d3 is just a dead draw but
after Bishop d3 what do you think that I
played here in this position yes
somebody from the YouTube channel he
already said the move that I played it
looks interesting on the first side no
this is okay this is just blundering
upon yeah I thought I was too smart
yeah so again I was thinking about
deflection so I wanted to deviate this
Bishop from the e2 squared Bishop e4
that's a move I played and loses in the
spot yeah I'm gonna tell you why now
okay I was just thinking okay he can
never take cus then I go e to anyone but
I was just not counting well so I didn't
know how to count
even with my fingers so he goes B should
be too of course then I can take maybe
even this pawn on f5 and then maybe it
could be even women but the thing is he
can't just take this Bishop my point is
on the sake Frank he's punished on the
seek run we're gonna promote at the same
time and the thing is when he promotes
is going to protect this Bishop so I'm
just a piece down so the game continued
e to a 7 e 1 a a and I can just resign
so I played a little more moves a few
more moves so Queen d7 he manages
to avoid my checks getting continued
like that play Bishop III then Bishop d2
now it's going to bring this queen to f3
and no more chicks just now if I give a
check on d4 there's Queen f4 exchanging
Queens and I can just resign
so again continued a little bit but
after Queen c6 I resigned f6 f6
is hanging after King d8 Queen f6 and I
can just resign so this is how I lost in
the Spanish lick I hope you like the
game the bank or gambit is one of my
favorite ones and there are many
interesting ideas so thank you for
coming and see you in the next class
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you